good morning john i have not left this
room in about a week like i have not
gone out that door
which is
you know not great luckily it is a child
suite which means that i have there's
quite a long walk i can do
just from one one end of the room to the
other i did actually spend a little bit
of time in the top bunk just to
alleviate borden i also spent some time
over here it's a nice little spot at
first i was honestly like oh this ain't
so bad i'm gonna get a lot of stuff done
it turns out no i have cover and that's
meant not a lot of motivation and a lot
of sleep i'm doing covered tests i'm
doing one right now and it's also meant
a lot of watching i have a giant tv look
at this giant tv it's huge and i can
connect it to my phone i can watch
anything that my phone can do so the
last like five and a half years since
oren was born i think i've seen six
movies parasite knives out little women
coco and kanto and into the spider verse
and i decided i'd just go ahead and
double that in a matter of days and so
since i have nothing better to do here's
seven movie reviews in four minutes i
started out with dune and i was pretty
fevery at this point so i'm not sure if
she should take my opinion super
seriously i've also watched a lot of
dune content over the years i sort of
had the thought while i was watching it
why like it felt a lot like all of the
other dune things i've consumed if the
answer to why is because movies look
better now they're prettier than yes
okay i accept it looks very good the
vibes are very strong i'm definitely
gonna watch the next one i cried one
time during this movie second we watched
shang chi which i really loved i was
really in it i did start to think that
maybe i'm a little bit over superhero
movies and their ability to turn every
single plot point into a fight or chase
scene i know that that's the whole point
of a superhero movie so like it's not on
shanghai but
i cried two times during this movie one
was because of katie the other was
because of a dragon third suggested by
sam reich was derek delgadio's in and of
itself which was
the best thing maybe i've ever seen this
a live audience one man show
kept my attention better than shang chi
and its thousand intricately
choreographed fight scenes i did not
look away from the screen for a moment
it was definitely the best 90 minutes i
have spent in this hotel room i cried
maybe 300 times and saying that that was
my favorite thing was something because
of number four everything everywhere all
at once which i have heard lots about
and for the first like 30 minutes maybe
i was like yeah yeah this is what i was
expecting they didn't just make a
cerebral sci-fi kung fu thriller and
they didn't just make it hilarious and
absurd they also made it all about the
only thing that matters which is people
loving each other and those rocks the
rocks john i was so worried that they
were gonna do this thing to me but they
didn't do the thing to me and then they
went and got that raccoon accurate count
of number of cries gotta be in the
double digits number five uh lighthouse
i get why people suggested that i watch
it but i will remind you i'm trapped in
a hotel room really good movie at
letting you know what it feels like to
be insane my subconscious did put me to
sleep during it like i had to pause and
go back a while because i fell asleep
which worries me like what what about
that did you find relaxing i did not cry
during this movie number six detective
pikachu which i watched directly after
lighthouse for some reason but in a
weird way not knowing very much about
pokemon a similar kind of fever dream
frankly i was delighted i was not
surprised by all but one of the plot
twists the guy who does the voice of
pikachu a plus great and i cried zero
times but it almost got me it really did
and our final film was palm springs
which i did not know about until craig
benzene told me about it i think a lot
of people might hear like the synopsis
of this one and be like well i've
already seen groundhog day and no very
different but you know also funny and
touching and extremely clever a lot of
conversations we're bound to be having
right now i liked it a lot and i cried
one time john i'll see you on tuesday